mais c'est totalement mensonger jean
castex dit n'importe quoi c'est militer
à dix ils ont connu pour beaucoup
d'entre eux des situations de conflit
des opérations extérieures des pays où
c'était le chaos au mali en afghanistan
ou même ailleurs
donc ils sont conscients de ce que peut
être le chaos dans un pays il dit
simplement que l'armée risque d'être
appelé par les pouvoirs publics c'est de
ça dont il s'agit
si jamais là aussi qu'on a une situation
de désordre total c'est gérard collomb
lui-même qui quittant la place beauvau a
dit demain risque d'être face à face
donc yann rien il ya une malhonnêteté
intellectuelle de la part du premier
ministre et un manque de lucidité total
et quand je vois ce matin le général
lecointe chef d'état major des armées
qui annonce des sanctions contre ceux
qui se serait affranchi de la devoir de
réserve alors que lui même
dans la même interview s'affranchit
totalement de son devoir de réserve il
le fait sans doute sur instruction de
l'elysée
anglès affranchi de son label critiquent
ouvertement je cite les femmes et les
hommes politiques qui aujourd'hui
instrumentalise l'armée etc
il fait de la politique monsieur
lecointe alors qu'il est chef
d'état-major des armées qu'il est non
seulement en activité mais en
responsabilité et et dans le même temps
il explique que les généraux deuxième
ception qui ne sont plus en service
actif et bien font l'objet de sanctions
parce qu'ils se sont affranchis leur
devoir de réserve mais c'est absolument
incroyable à la fois d'incohérences et
de et de légèreté
voilà donc moi je dis simplement que le
général lecointe à mieux d'écouter les
militaires d'écouter les militaires de
terrain qui s'inquiètent de la cide
légitimement de la situation du pays et
pions pour elle a exprimé un petit peu
de respect parce que ces militaires qui
ont qui se sont mis au service de notre
pays et qui ont été loin puisqu'ils ont
été jusqu'à jusqu'à prendre le risque de
perdre leur vie quand ils étaient dans
des théâtres d'opérations extérieures il
mériterait un tout petit peu de respect
de considération de la part du
gouvernement plutôt que d'avoir les
propos méprisants de madame manière une
échelle dont on voit bien qu'elle
connaît rien au sujet et que et qu'elle
s'exprime chez les sujets voilà avec une
légèreté incroyable
excusez moi l'extrait convient de voir
le jeu castex ne parlait pas de la
tribune par des de l'attitude de marine
le pen et le pen elle a simplement dit
que ses militaires avaient raison de
s'inquiéter
elle est dans son rôle politique on a
quand même le limiter à 10 on est
arrivés à la situation de d
rythmant de l'état et de la nation avec
des situations très grave et un
gouvernement qui n'est pas à la hauteur
de 99 9% des signataires sont des
militaires retraités si j'ai bien
compris donc il nous ils ne sont plus
contraints par le devoir de réserve
voilà et les autres c'est des généraux
deuxième section celles qui ne sont plus
en service actif
voilà mais nous nous faisons de la
politique et nous essayons d'apporter
une réponse politique
nous pensons que ce chaos et ce
délitement de l'état n'est pas
inéluctable donc c'est bien normal que
marine le pen comme candidate à la
présidentielle et principal adversaire
adema de macron et bien disent qu'elle
tient compte parfaitement elle tient
compte bien sur elle dans son analyse et
dans son projet politique de cette
préoccupation légitime des militaires et
d'ailleurs ce qu'ils expriment c'est
finalement d'une certaine manière un
petit peu ce qu'avait exprimé le général
pierre de villiers parce qu il
ils avaient été envoyés dès le début du
quinquennat des macros simplement parce
qu'il avait dit un certain nombre de
vérités sur la situation du pays et sur
le manque de moyens des forces armées
[Musique]